foreign
[Music]
how did we get so lucky to come so far
this family is ready to come back
together it's a dream come true I mean
it's definitely bucket list for sure oh
we're at the Apex of his franchise fast
the heart and soul of The Fast and
Furious franchise boots on the ground on
location the more movies we make the
bigger they get we continue to outdo
ourselves because we owe it to our fans
the enormity of everything hits you like
a right hand of the jaw you still know
how to drive every time I'm on set I
have to pinch myself
you are now a Toretto I just have been
badgering them to participate in this
it's such an honor to be part of these
family that's the problem with having
such a big family how do you choose the
ones you saved are so lucky
guitar
[Music]
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are
building This Magnificent family
going on in that head of yours something
a little piece of it he said Dad
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear boom
such a beautiful life filled with love
and family I never got a chance
you stole that from me
my future
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
by peace
[Music]
[Applause]
he's coming for you with everything
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
never accept death when suffering is old
[Music]
set up
tear us apart
when it used to be about winning we
raised for respect
today I race to stop the bloodbath
[Music]
that's the problem with having such a
big family how do you choose the ones
you save
looks great
[Music]
[Applause]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime
[Music]
recognizes game
foreign
[Music]
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
[Music]
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]